federal governments go ahead for a
second coronavirus vaccine the food and
drug administration granted emergency
authorization
use for the moderna vaccine last night
this sets the stage for millions of
doses of the shot to start being shipped
tomorrow and it cannot come soon enough
with chronovirus continuing to ravage
the country
there were nearly a quarter of a million
new infections on friday another new
record for a single day more than 114
000 people were hospitalized all as the
death toll in this country tops
313 thousand tom hansen begins our
coverage right here
in new york tom good morning good
morning jeff well after more than 16
million cases and 300 000 deaths the
modern vaccine
the second to be approved by the fda
will arrive at hospitals like this one
where frontline health care workers will
be the first in line to receive the
vaccine we're also told
that the elderly will be in that top
tier to get the shot
as modern's vaccine rolls out of the
labs and launches toward those who need
it most
the fda's peter marks underscored the
importance of this development
in a call with journalists last night
this is another crucial step in the
fight against the global pandemic
two covit 19 vaccines have now been
authorized in an expedited time frame
while adhering to the rigorous standards
for safety
effectiveness and manufacturing quality
that the american people have come to
expect
keep in mind the massiveness of this
undertaking
the united states has launched the
biggest vaccine drive in its history
fifty thousand received pfizer's vaccine
this week
we will crush this outbreak that has
really
terrorized us for the last 11 months
the moderna vaccine has been shown to be
94.1 percent effective overall
for the patients in its trials dropping
to 86.4 percent
for those 65 and older like pfizer it
requires
two doses
dr gia tyson a louisiana
gastroenterologist and transplant
hepatologist
received her first dose thursday how are
you feeling today
i feel great a little arm soreness but
that's it
otherwise i ran 3.2 miles this morning
but for the vaccine to be effective
there has to be widespread approval by a
public willing to get the shots
this is really our way out and we are in
this together and so we have to get out
of this together
and the vaccine is a crucial part of us
kind of trying to get life
back to normal the vaccines arrive as 3
000
people a day die in the u.s i'm not
going to sugar cook this
we are getting crushed in california
there have been 150
000 new cases in just the last three
days
southern california hospitals are out of
regular icu beds
in the north a preventive emergency
alert went out friday
telling 7 million people in the san
francisco area
to stay home one shocking projection
68 thousand deaths could take place in
california
and more than 560 thousand nationwide
by april 1st as promising as these new
vaccines are
people and their behaviors are still the
most hopeful way
of stopping the spread you've been on
the front lines
for an exhausting nine months how
significant
is it that we now have two vaccines that
have cleared
fda hurdles it's wonderful i'm not sure
how much really the general population
understands the significance
you know of this
and with the end of 2020 approaching
americans are being urged to stay home
and only social in smaller groups
the surge that we're seeing today with
more than 3 thousand people
dead each day is in part linked to
thanksgiving
when millions of americans travel
michelle
3 000 a day that is a huge number tom
thank you